l'école primaire de Justin Oudin a
accepté de nous ouvrir ses portes élèves
enseignants parents on parlé à cœur
ouvert de leurs attentes réciproques
leurs difficultés ou leurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
espoirs à la maison tu es obligé de de
faire de tout manger et puis non bah si
quand même ouais mais de toute manière
ici on est entre copains on parler tout
ça donc c'est quand même mieux ici parce
que tu as moins de chos à dire à tes
parents qu'à tes
copains parce que c'est on
peut je peut te parler d'une d'une d'une
autre façon on peut se parler de ce
qu'on a fait de ce qu'on a fait en face
et de ce qu'on va faire alors que les
parents ils savent pas ce qu'on a fait
en classe et ce qu'on va
faire il vous manque vos parents pendant
que vous êtes à l'école vous y pensez ou
vous les oubliez oui oui toute la
journée moi ça me manque pas trop moi il
manque pas tellement parce qu'en fait on
a un temps pour les voir on nous donne
quand même du temps pour les voir donc
moi je trouve que le weekend et le
mercredi on a je trouve qu'on a assez
temps pour les voir ou plôt avec elle
comme on se couche tôt on a pas on n pas
beaucoup de temps aussi parce que le
matin on se réveille on va se laver on
se prépare et on part à l'école et quand
on revient de l'école il nous reste à
peu près 2h pour les voir bon 2hur c'est
suffisant pour leur parler de l'école
tout ça mais si on veut s'amuser un peu
avec eux sortir quand même les 3/4 du
temps à l'école ouais
donc même pas les 3/4 on est toute la
journée jusqu'à 5h30 oui mais le soir
vous parlez d'autre chose avec vos
parents moi je leur dis que ça s'est
bien passé ensuite je file dans ma
chambre et puis voilà moi c'est pas
pendant l'école que mes parents il
manquent c'est c'est surtout le soirf ou
quand je fais mes devoirs parce que ils
sont ils sont pas souvent là quand mes
parents ils sont de congé quand je fais
les devoirs avec ma mère et ben elle me
dit toujours moi je vérifie pas les
devoirs je vérifie l'orthographe alors
comme je fais plein de fautes ça ça
m'énerve un petit peu elle ne s'occupe
que de la matière dans laquelle tu es
mauvais c'est ça ouais voilà alors tu
peux pas lui montrer ce que tu fais de
bien si je peux lui montrer mais euh euh
elle aime bien elle préfère regarder mon
orthographe est-ce que c'est facile de
faire vos devoirs le soir à la maison ça
dépend ça dépend parce que quand tu as
pas assette place que tu as une chambre
pour deux par exemple quand tu as un
frère ou une sœur ben euh tu es obligé
de aller dans le salon et puis si euh
ton grand frère si tu en as un travaille
où tes parents regardent la télé tu es
dérangé tu es pas concentré du
tout c'est ce qui t'arrive c'est ton cas
ouais c'est mon cas mon frère regarde
beaucoup la télé ou alors il joue à
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur dans la grande
pièce impossible de faire les
doigts si tu as pas asse de place dans
ta chambre tu as pas de bureau tu
travailles par terre c'est pas agréable
ou alors dans la cuisine encore pire
pourquoi c'est pire sur la car je CIS
c'est pas ça mais comme un une j'ai une
petite table moi de la
cuisine à côté il y a la soupe qui cuit
j'aime pas la soupe moi je pense que les
parents il faudrait qu' qu' pense un peu
près à tout par exemple pour des parents
il s'occupent pas trop du travail et
pour d'autres il s'en il s'en occupe
pratiquement tout le temps il faudra qu'
qu'il s'en occupe mais par exemple qui
qui regarde ce qu'on a à faire ça c'est
normal par exemple moi des fois quand je
fais des devoirs mais mes parents quand
je trouve pas et ben ils viennent puis
ils me disent tout tout le temps la la
réponse ce qui fait que je fous rien je
je peux pas chercher ah oui alors tu
voudrais qu'il te laisse trouver déjà
qu' me qu' me laisse chercher un petit
peu parce que si j'ai une cervelle c'est
pour quelque chose c'est pas pour qu'on
me dise la réponse à chaque fois c'est
c'est fous ce qui s'occupe plutôt de mes
devoirs c'est c'est fou euh plutôt que
que je l' dis j'ai les cahers à signer
c'est fou ce que plutôt de signer mes
cahers ils sinttéresse à mon travail ben
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien pour toi
ben V dire il pourrait peut-être penser
à signer mes cahers parce que le
lendemain je suis pas dans le dans le
pétrin ah oui tu es dans la punition
surtout hein est-ce que tu as des frères
et sœurs ah non je suis fils unique et
j'en suis très fière mais c'est pour ça
qu'il s'occupe autant de toi tes parents
ah quoi que quoi que quoi peut-être
uneidé pour qu'il me lâche la grappe un
petit peu
ça serait quoi l'idéeétait
pas
ben je sais pas mais je je trouverai un
moment je
trouverai bien c'est ça comme ça ils me
lâcheront la grappe qu'est-ce qu'ils
font tes
parents bah ils font tout le temps ils
travaillent il travaillent mais comme
métier qu'est-ce qu'ils font ben ma mère
elle est comp
comptable puis on peur ben gendarme
la plupart du temps ça se trouve la
plupart du temps il est 8 mois en
yoslavie d'autres fois il a d'utre fois
il va Royant sauter en parachute donc la
majorité du temps il est pas avec
nous
mais je je suis pas très content que mon
père soit gendarme parce que là là j'ai
une école j'ai j'ai j'ai des super potes
puis là comme je vais bientôt partir en
Australie ou un truc comme ça ben je
pourrais plus les voir je obligé de de
me faire d'autres copains ça m'énerve
avant je suis à T je me fais copains
après je vais à Paris je me fais
d'autres copains puis après je change
beaucoup d'école toi ah oui à chaque
fois ça fait combien de temps que tu es
ici pardon parce que bah là là je suis à
icio depuis 3 ans j'étais TR 4 ans tu
étais déjà là ouais à 4 ans j'étais déjà
là mais je reste je reste pas longtemps
à chaque fois quelque part dans là l'été
prochain je pars ça se trouve encore
c'est l'été qui vient quoi c'est mais
c'est pas assez pour pour pour être avec
ses copains on a j'ai pas assez de temps
est-ce qu'il y a certains d'entre vous
dans les parents n'ont pas ne viennent
pas à l'école parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps bah moi enfin moi ils viennent que
quand ils ont un jour de congé mais
c'est c'est pas ils viennent pas très
souvent quand ils ont le temps quoi mais
tout le temps ça j'aimerais pas tout le
temps mais est-ce que vous vous avez
envie que vos parents soient au courant
de ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
l'école et viennent dans l'écolei quoi
pas toi pas moi sinon il me ferait
travailler tous les jours je pourrais
pas je pourrais pas jouer je serai mort
mais vraiment mort se est mon
destin pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne in mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche